thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much remember me the
Macaulay Culkin of 1927 yes sir I
remember when they first handed out the
Oscars in nineteen three I was home
alone too but that kid is something you
realize he's getting five five million
dollars for his next picture for this do
we need child labor laws anyway this is
the 63rd Academy Award and I'll tell you
I love Oscar I've seen him so many times
and I love him that little bald head I
didn't know that Sinead O'Connor had
kids but it's wonderful to be here in
person I attended that I couldn't be
here in spirit so I'm in person actually
I'm
Act actually I'm here to salute welcome
back our fighting men from Saudi Arabia
Tom
Tom Brokaw and dan Rather
no other war was like a football game
Saddam won the coin toss and elected to
receive I said it was over faster than
you can learn how to say Schwarzkopf I
think with a tough fight but I think CNN
won it was over like a big burst it was
like roseanne barr sitting on a whoopee
cushion now I heard Hollywood were
gathered to toast a century of movie
memories personally I never drink on
Oscar nights it interferes with my
suffering when most people really
reminisce about their first movie they
saw they get a warm glow in their heart
not me I tried to sit in the theater and
I had a warm glow in my fist of the
manager caught me I'd let that be a
lesson to you kids always pay to get in
the movies
the Japanese need the money to pay
Michael
everybody has memories of going to the
movies it's like sex you always remember
the first one showed by Kerchak workmen
asked a few stars to recall their first
times and put their answer together like
this you asked me to think of movies and
movies were my absolute passion from the
first time I didn't want to be a stage
actress I want to be a movie actress and
the thing that finally absolutely insane
was manslaughter that's really I thought
oh I could do that I die of joy I
remember going to the Karthi circle
theater as a young lad and seeing wings
gah remember some a West WC feel Laurel
and Hardy Chaplin of course I remember
just almost falling into the aisles when
he ate his boots it was a bed sheet
stretched between two stores in
Mississippi The Grapes of Wrath
the first know I remember is the early
with Gregory Peck movie back and I
remember seeing Rudolph Valentino and I
I liked him but then there was always
that terrible scene in a tent I just
remember being at the drive-in and just
looking up and thinking wow I I want to
go there I want to you know I want to do
that the home of the brave
Laros but but I didn't think it was all
that great because um it was my father's
movies so when I saw um Tammy tell me
true that was for me the real apex Dumbo
Dumbo Bambi it was Bambi like everybody
else
101 Dalmatians yeah absolutely
Tarzan of the Apes I used to love to
watch that waiting for his what do you
call our thing well I always liked the
westerns because it's the good against
the evil with a good always winning out
the Prince rides up when he picks the
white up and kisses her and brings her
back to life and scoops her up onto his
horse and rides off into the sunset and
it took me about 30 years to recover
from that one as the witch appeared
my mother put her hand says under the
sea ticket and she stuffed me under the
seat where I could hear that I remember
very well a shop of a lovely lady in
white walking down the stairs and then
at the bottom of the stairs was a coffin
and up roast AHA Lugosi
whoever so darn scary I was afraid to
look at it and yet I'd love to look at
it buuuut signals I was never impressed
with I remember looking up and noticing
that her nostrils didn't match Godzilla
King Kong I wanted the the egg to win
the shape of things to come I still
would like to believe there's such a
thing as a flying carpet just sat there
my mouth wide open
Oh first of all that I've ever went to I
remember Grace Kelly I remember thinking
that uh Gary Cooper forget it he's dead
I remember a lot of green I remember I
didn't wet jailhouse rock
Elvis Presley and sex it was 1957 and
the movie we saw was George Formby in
it's in the air The Birth of a Nation
mr. Lowe's holiday gonna get in Peyton
Place um I like come on I think it must
have had Charlton Heston in it because
he was in every first movie that I saw
the lives of a Bengal Lancer with Gary
Cooper first movie I ever saw was the
first movie I was in I went to the feta
to see it I was sitting alone then like
I am now the first movie I ever remember
seeing was Exodus and my family just
sawed it with like the greatest movie
ever made my mother took me to the east
to show the Radio City musical was Bob
Bye Birdie
rebel without a cause and I saw that one
three times Lily
I saw it nine times strangers will come
up and I said up I remember you in a
movie and they go on and they say no you
you were you were in this room and she
said so and so and you turned and that
look that you gave her I I said that's
kind of like a little piece of time that
they remember the picture
but reserved understand was the digital
world I asked my mother what that said
because there was something beautiful
about the ruby red letters and she said
it was been her I thought well good
maybe I'll catch that one chance and
gone with the wind was facing it was
about me
David Lee as long as we're able
I remember this little house that spun
up into a tornado and landed in the
middle of this perfect little land and
this little girl walking John Gilbert
Gothel they were a passion with me I
absolute passion and Johnny Aubert
a matinee idol oh yes your word how can
you ask that your ignorance of Paul's
face Oh God it was thrilling
there are more Academy Awards coming up
with Whoopi Goldberg and Robert De Niro